an entire home completely destroyed
flattened by a huge gas explosion
so loud neighbors thought a bomb had
gone off
a woman who was inside was killed
a seriously injured man rescued by
neighbors who carried him out of the
burning wreckage on a mattress
the family in this car were driving past
the moment the house blew up
they were lucky to suffer just minor
cuts
it's just explode you know like all the
airbags came out
the rear seats and the front seat and
all the windows of the car even the roof
was damaged then all the neighbors came
out and they took one man out a few
larger and inside they took one man out
and he was injured
the group of rescuers described as
heroes by emergency workers kira's
partner was among them
i know that they brought a man out on a
mattress
um i know they was willing to help a
lady but they couldn't actually get to
the lady
um and just
everyone's just really shocked and sad
the house had been up for sale the
details listed that the boiler needed
fixing but investigators are still not
sure what caused the gas leak
up close you can see the devastating
impact of this explosion an entire home
furniture and possessions reduced to a
pile of rubble with debris thrown across
the road
i think it's fair to say that the
destruction on this level um
any um injury or loss of mice is a
it you tragedy it could have been um
they could have been more
among the rubble are signs of the lives
that were being lived before the blast
that tore everything apart
becky johnson sky news birmingham